>> Hi, YouTube. My name is Phillip Jennings.
I'm the General Secretary of, uh, UNI Global
Union.
I'm here at Davos this year with the Trade
Union Delegation to put
workers' issues at the forefront of the agenda.
Very often, uh, the problems of working people
and the problems they
have in their daily working lives is, uh,
often forgotten here IN the
discussion so what we do is try to bring an
alternative VOICE to the
discussions that are taking place.
The world of globalization is not working
for working people.
One in two people at work are now in vulnerable
employment.
The share of wages and the wealth produced
is as low now since record
were kept since the Second World War.
That is to say, the economic pie is actually
growing but the share of
wages and earnings of workers is actually
in decline.
We are faced with catastrophic inequality
in this global economy of
ours.
If you look at the roots of the Subcom crisis
why did it happen?
It happened because people at the low end
of the income scare -- scale
could not meet their debt, could not meet
their repayments and that
has spiraled into a global financial contingion.
In seeking solutions I ask all the participants
here at Davos, the
business people and governments, to think
of the people in the center
of this storm and I think in this process
we should also recognize the
role that unions play and the rights of trade
unions to organize.
This year we have the 60th anniversary of
the ILO Convention on the
Freedom of Association.
Never has there been so much pressure on working
people to turn away
from trade unions.
We see abuses of trade union rights all over
the world and if we're
gonna make a dent in inequality, if we're
going to improve the working
conditions of people, then we need those rights
to organize and we
need -- we need to negotiate working conditions.
You defeat inequality by a fair bargain and
a fair bargain has to be
done by strong social partners and a strong
trade union movement and
that's why we are here to -- to bring this
message.
We are here talking to business leaders and
to -- to government about
dealing with these people -- uh, issues.
My one hope that in -- in our work is that,
uh, the 250 million
children at work should be able to go to school.
It is a global scandal that we are still facing
250 million people
under the age of 14 are at work.
It's also a scandal to us that many governments
are trying to attract
investment around the world by eliminating
trade union rights and
export processing terms.
15 million people export processing term where
there's no right to
organize.
So let's celebrate the 60th anniversary of
the right to organize,
let's help rebuild the National Trade Union
Movement, my friends in
the Global Trade Union Movement.
We are ready to innovate, we are ready to
collaborate but not just to
collaborate but two negotiate for a fairer
deal for working people on
this planet.
It can be done.
It takes political will, and there's organizations
out there like UNI,
fighting for you to improve -- uh, to improve
your working conditions
and your standards of living.
Thank you, YouTube.
Best of luck.
Thank you.